got a whole lot of love
wow you got a whole lot of love name
that band brian
oh let me see
um
i don't know led zeppelin okay i was
just making sure you knew my favorite
group of all time i didn't know i didn't
know if you could i don't know if you
knew sounds like you're british right
i'm british
yeah they're british
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that stuff will frustrate me
oh i thought you're asking brian's
brother
well when you said i said i said i was
talking about my told flip-flops and i
go they got koi print they got tiger
print yeah they got dragon prince you
got it all he goes and you go dragon
leather you get to have dragon litter i
go yeah and then you go
wait
they got dragon leather flip flops
no i did it yeah you did although they
have alligators i did it
alligator might as well be a dragon it
might as well be a dragon you have to
use when you make anything with with uh
with a [ __ ] alligator
or crocodile
um because he gets like he gets uh he
gets
nile crocodiles salt water crocodiles
crocodiles
but you can't you have to use the
underbelly
wait i have a trigger i have before i
want to hear all about this um because
we're talking about leather
leather i'm going to give you i'm going
to give you i want to hear that is this
the strongest leather what's the
strongest leather
in the world and they make motorcycle
suits out of it because it's got the
strongest abrasion resistance and you
can use it as as like when you weave
something it's stronger than anything
else yeah it's an animal a human it's
weird human leather no human skin no not
human skin snake lamb not snake snake
very weak not lamb
so so let me let me go so so herman oak
that i'm i'm wearing right now yeah
that's that's cowhide then they take
it's like herman oak is the best they
they use saddle leather
world okay yeah now that that's awesome
where's catec
strongest i guess taking a [ __ ] don't
say that so now what if i what if
jim was [ __ ] and he's all
right he just started swinging the nose
there she is there she is hey what's up
kitty cat
brian just hit us with a trivia question
okay
no one will get it
it's weird though the strongest letter
in the world that's not bad it's not a
bad that's not about it
it does have two legs it has two it's
got two legs it's not an ostrich it's
got it's got two legs and it's not an
ostrich and it's the strongest leather
in the world they make motorcycle suits
out of them kangaroo yeah
[ __ ] a isn't that weird kangaroo of
all things kangaroos good job it's tough
to you know you can eat kangaroo uh in
australia it's like eating i guess deer
meat out there oh yeah yeah really she
kangaroo hundred percent
yes fine did you try it when you were
out there i did not i didn't see it on
the menu
yeah that's probably
good they're they're vegetarian people
say i mean rogan swears by it i'll kill
rue i'll i'll eat it
well i won't kill uh i don't want to
kill a root but i'll eat one i'll fight
one
yeah i'd like to see that yeah it would
be a fight huh no i think you'd get
[ __ ] up the big males because they
it's their big mess
they lean back on the tail it's not
their stupid hands it's their big tails
no no no and their feet no they're
looking their big feet kick you right
stupid tail and [ __ ] i think they
kick off their [ __ ] nails are like
super sharp yeah chin see how jump in
his pouch and [ __ ] him up you know i'll
jump right in that pattern you gotta get
real close i'll nose dive in that pouch
and just go to the bodywork
you
all right say how high a kangaroo can
jump i'm going to say 50 okay i'm going
to say 10 feet off the ground 10 feet do
you think that's fair do you think they
can dunk brian well you're that's stupid
right what do you mean you know
kangaroos can't jump 10 feet i'm
thinking they can they're they from the
ground six feet six feet in the air and
that's where you jump as high as a like
normal six being a kangaroo ten feet ten
feet
think about how high
that's insane i mean now that that thing
can jumps
how much do they weigh a big male
that's [ __ ] crazy 10 feet i was i
didn't realize yeah i thought that was
stupid but this also said
run 40 miles an hour which that's
[ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] though i
don't know if it's [ __ ] dude
200 pounds
200 pounds 200 pound kangaroo is going
to kick you right in your [ __ ]
stomach you have your hands 200. you got
your hands i'm not fighting it too
[Applause]
you want the 40 pounder no that's just
they can grow up to eight feet tall
oh my god seriously really
uh eight feet you want no part no dude
eight foot two hundred pounds brandon
come back ready
i'm back kick dick tail come back take a
look at let me let me see a couple of
these back you're jumping into that
scares me yeah i'm jumping that pouch
you're doing the body work and their
skin is too thick for you to do anything
that's impossible i'll put you on that
stupid [ __ ] nose
that's a big room you want no part of
that i want no part look at the balls
and then the females don't kick the
males do what the [ __ ] is going on
there's not real is it look at it look
at it back at the visual hey real quick
just the internet though you know no
dude the internet's all real that's a
big rule bro you think that's fake no
it's not fair no that one's real yeah he
looks pretty normal that's it that's a
giant room so crazy nate diaz i know
right
god damn that thing would go to that one
where it's on its tail chin which down
right there
how the [ __ ] like oh they come off
too yeah they used as a spring although
they only have one technique so i guess
you'd figure out a way to i mean chin
got real close to kangaroos i laid down
with one you did yeah i hugged them oh
they're pretty high the plane went
straight to the zoo so so but friendly
it was kind of like tainted i think
they're all nyquil they're over fed and
everything they're just
no like diabetic animosity yeah you said
they were like that with the koalas too
oh koalas were super drugged up now can
you not touch a koala because they have
chlamydia or some [ __ ] koalas yeah you
just gotta wash your hands
they have it like in their nose they
just naturally carry you i bet you that
ruse get taken by by crocodiles all the
time that's what i'm going to say god
they're [ __ ] big i didn't realize
what that [ __ ] bit
dude i saw some big-ass iguanas in
mexicano oh tell us about mexico you
weren't those those iguanas are eating
whatever tacos canelo ate yeah the
iguanas were huge they're big yeah
that's all the kids wanted to see yeah
everyone papa iguanas papa iguanas yeah
they're [ __ ] dinosaurs out there dude
they're big just sunbathing really just
soaking up the sun is that right the guy
was saying they there are so many well
that's me okay i'm very happy i've never
seen you that thin carnivore daddy there
never seen the poor daddy don't be mad
at the dick not weak don't be mad at the
big dick i'm happy with the dick now
your tail you don't have much of an ass
you know what it is it's the light i
don't know no the lights are into the s
i got tails peru yeah you kind of don't
have a tail piece in relation
look
is
that's when the ass pops the one where
they're like
bent over oh
you just got adrian peterson he just
here's the thing though so i forgot my
swimsuit your arms are as big as your
thighs yeah
damn near yeah you can't be mad at it
here's the thing here uh my girl goes i
have to take a picture all right enjoy
this so i took the pick carnivore has
been working right carp has been working
on the dad yes but i've i didn't pack a
swimsuit because i our flight was at 7
00 a.m and i decided to pack at 5 00 a.m
and that's never good when you're that
tired that's right i thought i packed a
swimsuit didn't so daddy i had to we had
our own private pool so i swear i'm
wearing my my undies and my girl's like
you need sunscreen so i said i don't
need it she goes i'm telling you the
mexico
sun is really strong alright what's the
same sun as in california right yeah
right but we know this [ __ ] right right
yeah so i went once you lather up the
kids because their their child skin is
soft like babies yeah so lather them up
and keep that devil lotion away from me
yeah now here's the thing the sun is
definitely hot it it is hot
it doesn't make sense because our
elevation is higher here so i figured a
little more south bubble a little closer
to the equator equator yeah there's the
problem that lies with all this and the
other thing is now when daddy's in his
underoos i have white uh very pasty
white well i thought he hasn't seen the
song that will will never that's not for
sure well it's never seen this song
that's the british part of it yes it is
you got lit up dude those my if i took
my pants off it is beat red and there
was nights i could not sleep it hurts so
bad
that's a new one but i'm so stubborn i
went she goes how are you i'm fine
because your legs are insanely relevant
no look at tan yeah and she's gonna hear
this to know she was right be let's take
a little break from chatham with
chappelle because man this saturday ufc
273 we got a calabasas fight campaign at
7 00 pm live on think boy youtube if
you're going to watch it with the boys
josh thompson matt mateo and brian count
and myself watch it with us and make
some bank with draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc new customers can bet five dollars
on any fighter and get 100 in free bets
win or lose it's guaranteed if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
yet you can still get in on the
excitement everyone can play for a share
of millions and prizes with the
draftkings daily fantasy mma contest
draft your lineup of fighters while
staying under the salary cap and rack up
points for strikes takedowns and more
draftkings a safe secure reliable best
of all you can deposit withdraw your
cash whenever you want download the
draftkings sportsbook app now use promo
code fighter throw down five dollars on
ufc 273 and get 100 in free bets no
matter what i bet hamzat the code
fighter this saturday at draftking
sportsbook the official sportsman
partner of the ufc 21 older restriction
supply
see show notes for details
you got to keep your hair dude dude i
gotta go you know this i gotta get back
on my finaster ride and keeps
is a company where do look first of all
you gotta realize two out of three men
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. more than 50 million
amer men in the us suffer from male
pattern baldness all right keeps has a
five-star review from any of its
competitors and there are two fda
approved medications that can prevent
hair loss keeps offers both yes keep
offer simple affordable stress-free way
to keep your hair 24 7 care and support
ask questions you talk to a real human
being you get a convert convenient
virtual doctor consultation yeah dude
the medications are delivered right to
your door every three months it's low
cost it starts at just ten dollars per
month all right keeps has everything you
need to keep your hair remember
prevention is key and by the way they
have discreet packaging so nobody has to
see that you're getting no nobody has to
know you look like fabio in four to six
months see results so act fast all right
if you're ready to take action prevent
hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot com
fighter to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's keeps.com
fighter to get your first month free
k-e-e-p dot com slash fighter my dad
when we went to new mexico and you spent
some time there i think or montana we
were in montana we're not in new mexico
we were in montana spent time in bowl
and my father shows up to ride horses my
mother says you have shorts on and he
goes yeah she goes you can't ride a
horse with the shorts and he said
i can
i'm a man i'm tough
and you know how you know how callous
the inside of your thighs are yeah
because there's the most delicate part
of your skin so my skin's so soft i mean
it's just yeah it's like veal it's so
soft i'd like to grab worst place to get
a tattoo by the way a hundred percent
yeah
um
and i wouldn't get one there no no
unless i spent my time with my legs open
in yeah
i would get a tattoo there if i suck
if i if i get the tattoo on their inner
thighs a lot of people really well yeah
probably gay people right no no
if i took them
a
i take a break if i took a break and i'm
just being if i took a break from my
straight lifestyle yeah and i went to
germany where nobody where i know no one
yeah let's be known and i went into
certain bars i would get myself a couple
tattoos you would show it off in the bar
old but willing in german it would say
old old
yeah like you like it medium and you
wear shorts up to here the whole time
uh-huh or
they're the
arrows there's my whole heroes that say
medium rare medium rare
and it wants to get well done yeah
but it's ready to be well done yeah
right that's cody
[ __ ] this out [ __ ] this
if you know what i mean yeah yeah
that's why
i just want to make sure that we're not
like confused
it's waters aren't murky yeah it's code
for bang my mud whistles
dude that reminds me they had one of
those fancy uh
uh toilets and where we stayed at this
resort that
that major [ __ ] you walked up today
and then there's a fan where it dries
your booty hole as you you take a dump
it sprays water up and down which is
weirdly uh feels nice it's great it felt
real gay but real nice so just did that
yeah and then you wipe your butt and
there's nothing it's just clean yeah
it's just clean yeah i told my girl i
came out now this is where she [ __ ] up
man in a comment because i came out
because we had dinner with friends and
she goes yeah brent uses that like weird
bidet electric thing i go oh you can
this guy who i don't know i had some
drinks i go you could eat that rib eye
off this brown eye that's how clean i am
oh god
it didn't go well you could eat this rib
eye off this problem
very good thank you sir i like that a
little bit of it we liked it they didn't
like it it did not go well with the
dinner party if you don't laugh at that
that's disgusting and i went is it or is
it
facts yeah and if you're not going to
laugh at that
then dude i want one of those in the
house it was so nice oh yeah it was
alarming how much i enjoyed that water
just
pressure on my it's better but when you
get up you're all clean
dude just [ __ ] streaks are gone but
you shouldn't be no more camouflage
undies
you should never have a sh you should
always have you should always have a
clean whistle always i have a bidet oh
you do yeah oh like well you rich rich
yeah in the house yeah it came with the
house no it didn't come with the house i
bought it
what yeah
yeah so there's there's ones on amazon
but they have these other ones that like
the [ __ ] that you were talking about but
it's like basically a new toilet seat
and it has all the buttons and washes it
for you then it has the air to dry it
for you you just boom very european of
you very yeah
oh i i i refuse to go back when i don't
have one i'm i'm i'm here oh game chat
dude is it forward to my morning yeah i
can't wait to have the thing massage my
tank yep you got to clean your [ __ ] then
i'm sitting on there and my girl's like
are you coming out i was in for about 30
40 minutes i need another 30 minutes
this feels way too i need more time i
might be a gay man that thing was
massaging my ass so like you wouldn't
just clean like warm water
now and then hit the fan just did you
hit the beach in may at the beach now
here's the thing about the beach in
mexico
in cabo off the baja coast is the water
the undertoad is no punk the undertowed
uh
undertone
they had a black flag
that was
just going like this because you
couldn't be in there you know
you just couldn't do it well when i was
there so so i went in by myself i swim
tiger's arm and i went i can't be that
bad how bad can it be well it was so
intense it would have swept tiger way in
a heartbreaking [ __ ] now daddy won the
water because daddy can swim right right
daddy
so i went in the water in my undies yeah
which that was a public beach i was
probably frowned upon look at boston i
win the water skewed as [ __ ] yep
i went in the water was your girl age at
all does your girl age it's unbelievable
yeah insane it's [ __ ] weird though
yeah i know i was looking at her you
sent me a video and she was in the
background yep and i may have taken a
little peek look at her body
does she age it's [ __ ] weird it's
funny when we got people think her bro
you just take a little peek it's fake
take a little peek
yeah no that's not fake her ass is that
way
for how long you know what's up
listen to me
i've known you for over 10 years she had
that booty
way back when well her mom has exactly
exactly yeah and i'm telling you that
that that's
that that was before that [ __ ] was gone
now daddy had some anxiety in mexico
because the fear-mongering media will
post about cartels and stuff when i say
i didn't sleep i did not sleep dude i
can't sleep it's all i thought about
right now but then uh stone chin this on
the shop show my girl whenever we like
going to the city
you know because she's from there she
speaks the language obviously she would
get become friends with the guy
whoever's driving us and then slowly as
they became friends she would go she
would ask about the cartel and he'd give
her like the lowdown and he was like
cabo's like the safest because they only
don't go because they own them no he
said because uh the one thing is the the
tourist attraction they're so
like massive for them but on the baja
coast where they're at they can really
only uh smuggle drugs through the ports
and the
mexico navy has cut that off from them
and it's not that big of a market so the
cartel went [ __ ] it and they've dealt
with everywhere else yeah cancun's a
problem cancun's a real problem really
because there's three cartels in the
middle of uh they're fighting for war
blood
and the thing is yeah stone chin this on
the shop show the thing is the cartel
members you know they're normal people
they're complete [ __ ] but they're
normal people they like to go with the
you know the tourist goat because the
dinners and drinks are nice the problem
is when you're there the other target
your target so the other cartels come in
they shoot so innocent people get shot
yeah i think the last two weeks five
americans have died there is that true
nuts yeah it's not wow
[ __ ] we get emails all the time people
are like oh detroit and south side
chicago and la you're more like you get
shot i hear all that i'm with you man we
have problems here but i know how to
move in la in detroit and chicago
speaking for my country i know exactly
where to go what not to do when you're a
foreign
mexico city which you don't think a fake
place you don't go there it's where all
the boxers like nacho bernstein okay
come out you don't go there unless you
know people you do not go into tibito
yeah and frank
was there and he just wandered off
during the shoot because he went to you
know inspite world for that for the next
yeah fight fight world it's great and he
goes and like talks he's still on
netflix yeah he talks to cesar chavez
that's great
and he he boxes with those guys really
cool
and uh he just during there was a break
and he kind of went off and went to go
buy some trinkets and stuff and dude the
guy came over and goes you cannot
[ __ ] do that
and the reason that he knew where they
were is the guys on the roof were
telling them
get your boy right now get your [ __ ]
boy out
because he was wandering in areas where
and he thought he was safe probably been
there a little too long
comfortable yeah dude but it's like we
had dinner at this uh on the resort on
saturday night and we were there on
thursday night
had dinner and we're walking back i
don't know it's probably 10 30 at night
we're walking back and a guy meets us it
was all gonna walk you guys back i was
like that's nice that's good customer
service let's turn behind me and there's
a guy in all black camo with a [ __ ]
ar-15 yeah i'm like why the [ __ ] is this
guy so i i'm holding bossy i'm like
something pops off and i put boston down
so i keep looking behind like what in
the [ __ ] is that guy doing
then we get to the house and as we get
to the house he just walks literally
walks off into the bushes just
disappears i'm like what the [ __ ] is
that guy doing
so that night i didn't tell my girl i
don't want her i wanted her to sleep so
that whole i couldn't say but i'm like
why the [ __ ] would that guy with that
ar-15 be there all night that's so
strange so the next one i go hey when
the guy comes in
to whatever
you know fill the diet cokes up i drink
a million diet coke sale ask him why
that guy with the air 15 was walking us
back to the room she was there was i you
didn't see him she goes no he was
directly behind us he was in the camo
black how do you not see him because she
was in front of me
so she asked him the guy goes oh there's
a uh
whatever a high-end celebrity staying
here who hired their own private
security so there's got there's five of
those guys just walking the premises at
all times
and they're a fan of you so they want to
make sure he was kind of just walking so
i go make sure i'm okay i said obviously
there's a heightened risk then if if
this whoever the celebrity has had to
hire these guys has to be a heightened
wrist the guy goes good chance
what height and wrist i'm like what
so that's why we got out the next
morning yeah
it's like that's
just it just doesn't make sense to me
yeah we don't need this man
that's why when you go to tahiti you
don't have to worry about it that's
expensive as [ __ ] but god too far flight
though it's
simply too far how far it's see what
where what bora bora because you don't
just go to barbara then you've got it so
far but even my girl like taking another
one we're going through cut like you
have to go through customs all the
checks and you have to get a covet test
a lot of stuff
this doesn't make sense to me like this
makes sense to me it's not too bad it's
probably 10 hours it's really 11 hours
but then you get there and then you have
to take i think another plant or
certainly a boat so
it's okay
it's beautiful
yeah it's just not working if i was by
myself whatever dude with kids my son
he did not want to be on i'm like oh we
got to get up i told my girl i'm like if
you don't stop crying
i just don't want to do this like let's
just go home it's not worth it he
stopped thank god but right now but i
still like like going through customs
and then you got that security there and
like yeah they are 50 i'm like and for
what wait so you still have to do a
covet test yeah to get back look i think
i think at the end of the day when you
live
when you live in l.a and you you can go
to
there are a lot of places in out like
malibu in places like
i know it's good to get away and stuff
but i don't know sometimes we just got
it right here go to san diego
san diego dude you got a newport san
diego there's so many great santa
barbara
what
oh hi
oh data point for the hassle just does
it yeah right for the hassle that makes
sense to me
it's tough because my girl's mexican
right sometimes i'll look at my girl and
then her and the kids are thriving
mexico i'm like oh that's right they're
mexican yeah
all that but also the kids are
reversible but also the kids are mexican
boston speaks better spanish but josiah
they're mexicans yeah their kids are
massive they both speak english
both the kids speak spanish oh yeah yeah
that's amazing i'll speak at this tiger
sometimes yeah bossy super
into spanish he understands spanish
better than anything he sings in spanish
i'll show you a video blow your mind
mm-hmm let's sing all twinkle twinkle
star in spanish
it's [ __ ] nuts that's cute he got
cuter in mexico really the glow up is
insane yeah yeah no them in their
outfits that that right there
the cute picture they're cute as [ __ ]
dude how about how about tiger thank god
that's the mom's cap
how about tiger and jiu jitsu yeah
seeing that video i want to post that
video but we're talking sorry i want to
post that video you're kind of oops i'm
just saying i want to post that video
but i sent to you but yeah go ahead
you're super upset oopsie um he uh
he the kid you sent me a video there's a
kid who's 11 in the class who beats the
[ __ ] out of everybody tiger at six
at six years old i was like oh boy and
just dangerous took him down and mounted
him and did whatever i was like oh
that's
yeah choke them out like
yeah you know what that rear naked i saw
that i was like yes that's athleticism
well the coach goes uh he lets the kids
pick we gotta go tonight matter of fact
he he lets the kids pick and he goes all
right who do you want picks the big 11
year old and i'll take tiger because
he's easy
oh dude
in front of the entire class he went oh
hell no and all the dad's like dude i'm
like no no shut the [ __ ] up oh tiger
come here in front of everybody i s
that kid's picking you because things
can be an easy go
you better
do something do not let him take you
down i don't care what happens do not
let him take you down give this kid hell
dude if you want that ice cream give
this kid
and then the dad behind me uh uh toby
who i [ __ ] love his sons in the class
he filmed me because i it was so intense
i saw it and then the parents said yeah
we don't know if we want this
environment
hold hold on what environment has
anybody competed here no no no no no no
all rich uh you know trust fund babies
cool
this is nothing
i want this oh
i want this all the way up i want to
crank this competition thing all the way
up it's not a bad thing no if your kid
can't handle it don't come to the cloud
yeah i was talking to some jiu-jitsu
also he's 11. yeah [ __ ] off yeah i was
talking to this this guy who who had
five mma fights and he's a eddie bravo
brown belt and uh
no i think jacques machado brahma and he
was he shot i did this little thing for
toehold so he shot the stuff and he and
he who makes all the sandals he's a
brown belt uh he's over at uh 10th
planet vegas and they're killers yeah we
don't kill us but they were talking
about the difference between between
dudes who compete
like when you compete excuse me and and
regular black belts and then
and then dudes who fight so so jiu jitsu
guys that are really good who also who
actually fight it's a very different
it's a different what do you wait what
do you mean in competing so you might
have your black belt okay in a class
okay and you might be good and you're an
instructor if you don't compete in
jiu-jitsu it's a different and you [ __ ]
with the guy who competes that's one
thing
then there's the guy who's also a black
belt and and loves jiu jitsu but also
fights mma mm-hmm and it's just they
were talking about the tempo and the
difference it's [ __ ] nice but yeah
the caveat to that is the guy who
competes and so is so solely focused on
jiu jitsu yeah he's mopped the floor
with the mma guys who's kind of one leg
scout yeah
with him because like when i stream with
bushes when he was just focused on jiu
jitsu
what
he's training as much as i train in mma
but just on jiu-jitsu and a ghee yeah
you're gonna get rolled the [ __ ] off
of course he's a nightmare of course
these guys are monsters monsters
yeah there's marcus almeida monster
that every bit of six three and 240
pounds right now that dude is that big
this guy you trained with mm-hmm yeah
[ __ ] beast man yeah one of the best
to ever do it monster god how would he
do against gordon ryan
hey prime fantastic yeah he's a monster
man have they trained i mean have they
fought each other i don't know they're
kind of two ships crossing the night
because he does a lot of ghee ah
so the uh i bet to see if they've
competed such a nice guy i met him with
you one time at metamorse yeah great guy
yeah
super freak
what are they calling bouche what does
that mean i don't know what that means
oh [ __ ] yeah 2019 2019 it's a little bit
so who won that i think i think gordon
right it looks like
this is 30 minutes jen yeah i'm gonna
fast forward i'm sure we can just look
at the results
you want to see them
i mean
this is high level [ __ ] huh the highest
level
so why is there this in the ghee what's
the difference one's no gi one ski so i
went to decision
i'm saying tai i'm saying i'm saying you
say tai i'm saying draw watch no i bet
you gordon ryan
don't know it looks i feel like he's
going to let raise both hands
he looked like he's about to raise both
hands
how did you get that because you can
fight to a stalemate no no how did you
get how did you get that it was it
looked like he was about to raise both
hands don't choose
both of them yeah he was just always
bald yeah nobody was about to no that's
stupid
sometimes i think i think it
metamorphoses there was a there was a
tie right there was a i mean mine was
basically a tie with cyborg yeah yeah
draw but that's that's straight up
i mean that's big boy stuff there's no
draws really in there those guys are
[ __ ] monsters the freaks of all three
jordan ryan i mean the bet one of the
best ever do it oh my god
roger grace yeah we didn't get started
too but yeah mexico was fun your boy get
tan as [ __ ] good
and and and you're good for about five
days no no no no what no i'm saying
three three my girl knows that though
three days like our like tiger's friends
went before us because we had dinner
with them uh they were there since
monday i was like i know i don't know
how you
i literally physically can't do it yeah
i'm good for two after two i checked the
box all right got away
did all that let's go man i can't do it
yeah did you go with uh friends
no tiger's friends were there they're at
another resort and then they met us for
dinner and then the kids would play but
five [ __ ]
no no all set on five days it's
impossible i got a new game i play in
the sand now
what
spike ball [ __ ]
is that where you throw the ball in the
little tree
yeah dude and daddy
um it looks fun i could get it it's
you'd no no no you'd love it remember
how much fun the [ __ ] stupid
volleyball was this is even stupider and
more fun it's just you get crazy with it
you get crazy with it it's so what do
you mean crazy go go but you got to see
it play it on youtube and stuff you
can't like it's just a different yeah
but the guys on youtube are pros yeah
but you get good quickly you don't have
a video of you doing it brian yeah i do
summer you get good quickly i'm telling
you you get good quickly
it's [ __ ] top 10 plays with spike
ball
you bang it and you just learn you can
see where somebody's going to hit it and
you're like okay these are called
yeah i'd rather watch
you [ __ ] a guy
yeah yeah yeah that's
so boring right
like i'm sure it's fun while you're
doing it but watching others play it
well i can't watch much on that but it's
it's exciting now you can't get too
excited about it let's not get too
competitive but you do oh hit it with
his back foot you're allowed to
you're allowed to it's stupid i see what
you're saying it's not one of those
watchable but you got it you got to be
here you do this in the sand yeah you're
going to you'll get to work at it trust
me you got to be in it to like really
are you all on a team yep it's two
against two oh two two right you get you
get down like that [ __ ] like you get
into it yes no brian's not doing it at
55 that's what i'm saying like right now
brian's not diving by the way i by the
way i was complimented by some onlookers
to say how the [ __ ] hold you i was like
don't worry about it they were like
all right that never you were getting
down like that i got i got a i got good
reaction a lot of folks i got a lot of
flexibility you know what i'll do i'll
tell you what for you guys and for our
viewers where's the video daddy's gonna
make a video for us of you playing
playing you don't have you don't have
one right now i got a [ __ ] who do
you play with
um i play with jeff foley our boy jeff
i played with my buddy
though
only one time
jeff flips very far only one time
yesterday yeah only on one time
yesterday i'm trying to my buddy mark my
buddy mark video randomly pull the video
out dude this is not playing a lot
you're not playing a lot pull the video
out daddy hey daddy we're not playing a
lot are we looking dude i'm playing
video out dude
yeah you've done this four times no hold
on that's not true i'm gonna go to pull
the video out because our friend jeff
would never drive to where you live and
play well jeff said i said he wanted to
play tennis and i this is a quote and i
said come come play um come play spike
ball and he goes
fine but i'm not sucking anybody's [ __ ]
it's but it was a lot of fun jeff is an
athletic monster himself jeff he makes
he looks like jeff still skates
49 years old could look better he always
wants to ride uh road bikes together but
i mean he goes so far he's a handsome i
don't have a [ __ ] too that hair isn't
rich i can't hit the lottery handsome
and rich he showed me videos of him
skating and [ __ ] he still gets
down his son's like oh yeah like number
one surfer yeah yeah
you got him a duke you're getting a dude
yes son's got a duke he's at like i
think harvard third yeah he's serious
yeah his other son
is being scattered by a bunch of d do
you wanna uh teams i'm helping them out
with uh
coach yeah
so you know
shoot the video
you sent you in the video no video no
videos i'll just send it to you okay
now you want now
now this is a clip dude man air dropped
that [ __ ] to him so you get that quicker
did that air drop right yeah ryan do you
you know that air drop or maybe
chappelle could do it for you just grab
yourself
just in case
drop it
so hit the
come on brian you got this oh it's
coming in sometimes it's coming yeah
christian's got you
but bottom line daddy's playing four
times two videos
so you don't play it a lot a lot hey
guys four friends come over i played
like five i played four because the way
they were getting down to these videos
he's not doing that
dude that's all those are college kids
that's all they do like in the fight
what are they called dude
what at tailgates yeah or not you can
tell what's the what's the common area
called in college campuses oh the uh
look at this there i am first of all
look at my body holy [ __ ] brian yeah
all right sick let's see it
where's the fourth guy
is there only three of you
there he
is is so brilliant this is
[ __ ]
so holy
go to the next video there's another
video yes sir
i told you it's a clip all right you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you guys man i'll show you
my [ __ ] when you ready we're going all
slowest
and brian went like this
[Laughter]
[ __ ] both of you guys man hey and which
one of those friends like dude here we
go again
is that the same one yeah same one
that one's not coming through dude
there's other ones
it's so slow hey who is the you and the
three on on athletic white guys
this one i'm just standing there
i like how you said i got moves doug
oh yeah
you're trying to convince us like you
[ __ ] go hard in the paint i go hard
to paint you're going to see me diving
and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah playing
for keith you guys are playing so slow
when i do that i go like this i go i
compared to those videos
that's like watching me box like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you i'd rather watch you box and do
that again
handball's taken over though it does
look i'll give you this look at like
four squares you'd be fine yeah i'd be
i'd be into it no you'd love it it's so
stupid it's so fun oh hey i just it's
actually an amazing workout because you
are diving and running and you're trying
yeah you weren't diving though you're in
the sand
i hear you but you guys
like you've moved maybe two yards that's
how much i did yeah yeah by the way you
high five the other two yeah what is
this top gun [ __ ]
volleyball i think ncaa championships
yeah whatever it was
down in mountain beach and i was there
watching these girls it was all women
these girls are i mean every single one
of them is bigger than i am i mean the
legs tall as [ __ ] [ __ ] and if they're
not tall they're thick and strong yeah
wait they had that going on down at the
beach yes and some of them are easy on
the eyes but frankly i'm a little light
in the air super dime piece yeah yeah
super diamonds yeah well they are tall
as [ __ ] you got to be like on the
squatters the ones that set up always
have asses oh gosh yeah those ones who
are they're kind of
shorter than my style yeah
the setters i think i don't like the
ones that spike it they're too tall
they're lean i like the thick ones that
just you ever been with a really tall
girl no no sir no no the answer is not
my vibe
but yeah oh he has paul big big too
what's that oh really what are you
messing about like my girl now no
no i'm saying a long time ago i don't
think so there are probably times i
don't think so i'm not attracted to that
there's only one girl
she's uh the tallest no like 5 10 bigger
than that no
yeah
and the sixes a huge young man
i know you're doing i don't like it and
you know what you're doing you're trying
to distract us from your haircut right
well here's let's not buzz it though
right here's the thing about it here's
the thing about daddy i
can't see as well now and i put a two
instead of a four on there and then i
went zoop and i went oh
no like kim says you got to maintain
what you have you got it and i went well
that's way too short and my girl even my
girl goes a little short huh this time
and i went a little short brian do the
plugs everyone's [ __ ] doing it and
everyone's proud to be doing [ __ ]
plugs yeah i feel like with one step at
a science just do it let me get this
okay let me get on testosterone before i
do that no do the pleasure plugs for
that yeah
do you know your handball game if you've
gotten tess
oh
right you'd be moving faster than that
right i mean not fast but faster than
that
daddy's got a stretch
[Laughter]
well yesterday was my
eight years off of alcohol yesterday i
hit eight years i hit eight [ __ ] jobs
dude yes he keeps trying to smell that
tiger thick i'm like dude stay away from
you can't get your relapse sam tripoli
just duke posted that he's been off porn
for like like i don't know a month or
something wait what all right
he's trying to get him
if you have to stay with me one time he
goes no i'm weird what does on porn mean
like he's just [ __ ] i think he's
watched all the porn and now he says
he's gone he's not drinking he's not
he's he's been sober for a year he's not
eating like sugar he's lost he's lost
like some 40 pounds and he's not
watching porn anymore i uh i tried a few
weeks ago i tried a non-alcoholic beer
no if i remember the point bro it was
yeah i was like oh no i can't do this
they gave me sick i was like if i have
like
another one of these i'll [ __ ] well i
had a sip of it and i was like if i
drink a full one
it was uh we were at a vegan joint i was
with uh jason ellis and uh toby and
someone was like get a uh jason ellis
got it he got a
non-alcohol you're like i'll try that i
was like i'll try a sip of it just and
it was i was like man if i had
all of that it's like being a vegetarian
and then you eat that fake meat just
don't eat the meat you know that fake
meat daddy daddy uh i forgot to tell you
this daddy went down the rabbit hole
thank you daddy went down the rabbit
hole it's hot as [ __ ] huh no daddy went
down rabbit hole this weekend daddy got
back into a little dmt
oh you did one and did some mushrooms
you did dmt without me
i did but i'll i'll get you involved no
no i don't want to involve come on
they've cheated on me no no no that was
our thing i know dude i'll get let me
get you back involved you were in mexico
and i said i had an opportunity to do
actual dmt and i was like tell us about
the trip what happened you know wait
here's hon where'd you do it at set it
up i did it in vegas okay what were you
doing in vegas i was with the show
oh that's right so you did it with them
yeah and so i uh well not with them oh
yeah i know we're just
so offended right it wasn't it wasn't
always
it wasn't with them it wasn't with that
it was just i had an opportunity i had
an opportunity but some people i know
not that well though no this one person
i know very well who do i know
he wants i don't know
do i know him um you cheated on me with
the dna but i don't want i don't want to
add them because i don't i haven't asked
them if it's okay to tell you so i uh i
i do mushrooms which i've done plenty of
times but not for years yeah before you
go in uh micro dosing or like full blown
i did a micro dose but i did a little
more than a microwave you feel it
until i did feel it and then i went
oh i'm i'm why am i staring at that
mountain for too long but where you at
when you did this i was in the shop when
my buddy was making my flip-flops a.g
was making my flip-flops okay and so as
he's making my flip-flops you know it's
a it's a it's hand he does it all by
hand so he's clipping he's cutting and i
was like this is too much man
yeah everything is moving too quickly
yeah and then i uh but but here's the
thing dmt awesome mushrooms awesome you
know what
i'm too old to have a life-changing
experience oh yeah no you know that that
ship sailed yeah right yeah yeah when
you're young and that's what it's
supposed to do is that's how i feel
about your braces you know yes yeah well
no hold on who's who was like hey dude
let's watch this man make leather
sandals and do shrooms
that was me
that'd be me
you wanted to have some fun i just i
would have been i'd be like well i'm not
doing this i had an opportunity this guy
makes sense no no i had an opportunity
to to micro dose and i said i'll take
one of those
let me see what micro dose is the pill
or chocolate the pill
a little much though a little more than
a micro dose and that's what happened
and i got kind of into you know but
what's really interesting about
mushrooms and they can't figure out what
it is and i heard jordan peterson
talking about it is that when people
have um cancer and it's an uncertain
diagnosis they might die whatever
they found and people with ptsd they
found that psilocybin trips even one if
done properly
can literally
change your neural chemistry or do
whatever it does to you where people are
simply and many times no longer afraid
of death yeah and accept their death in
in a way yeah and and it really has and
i i don't i'm not privy to these
experiments but there has been
measurable evidence that it [ __ ]
really does help in some cases
ptsd like that yeah that's why and they
don't know why they don't know why but
they know that there are there are
different levels of consciousness well
there are different levels of
consciousness we don't the brain itself
that they were talking about is is it
like the if you look at the bottom of
the ocean the deepest ocean we don't
know [ __ ] about it it's like the brain
is even more of a mystery but we do know
you can you can you can have
uh episodes of consciousness change the
road yeah yep but also also that are
positive not negative so it used to be
that when if you did a trip it was like
considered it's going to be negative not
so the the shift in scientific thinking
is it actually can be a very attitude
going into it
so did you feel any what like
i appreciate it i like psychedelics no
no did you have like any any type of
experience to where
like you felt something
life change
at 55 you want to know my real my my
real opinion on [ __ ] everything in
psychedelics
i think i think psychedelics are
there
no i think i think that they're there
because
they bring you back to the original
idea of god
in other words
if you if you really like if you really
like
get the through line of all the
religious traditions yeah in a lot of
ways people who come out of psychedelic
trips go i think there's something to
that [ __ ] that's going on there i think
there's something to stuff like that
yeah
yeah a lack of a lot not as afraid of
death sure sure
can you set the dmt uh table first how'd
that go down when you cheated on me dmt
last time we did with a shaman
yeah dmt is about dmt is about as
euphoric as you can get you kind of
leave your body
and did you smoke it again yeah
and where and how was this time
did you cry do you laugh as hard as we
did i think i saw what i'm the most
afraid of and i need to go into what
that's about wow right so so carl jung
said did you see a crocodile or
something stupid i did i saw a croc i
was looking at the globe
and all the clouds came together it's
funny
and they showed the top of a crocodile
really and i went wow well we know how
this ends yes one with the craw i gotta
swim
i gotta spin with the crocs right
comments
like why
this is my journey i'm like let me is
faces of death still available they're
looking for content and while i was on
my dmt thing i went i went i literally
went
man if i jumped in the water with a croc
right now it would still suck all the
dick i guess i'd be terrified
i don't think there's any way to face
that fare though you know
i mean you don't want to be scared of
crocodiles well don't you should be
scared yeah but that's it yeah that's
yeah but with dmt like you do kind of
like forget your bodies there
right okay you go it's out of body
experience yeah my i like you don't
necessarily feel your body no what are
you what did you feel
i i just remember i was like
launched into this like gold warm space
it was like heaven i was like floating
around and you felt like see right you
go kind of i could no i mean you don't
see what's in front of you i mean your
eyes are closed so you're like it's all
you know you're not like blacked out no
no you shoot off somewhere bro and he
started laughing and it sounded like he
was going oh oh like it sounded like it
was in an echo to you
it sounded like aubrey was like do you
laughing so loud you gotta pipe down
like i can't i was laughing so hard
i was doing this i was going oh
it's so creepy he was so creepy oh
really and you just saw a crocodile huh
i saw a crocodile it didn't sound very
funny what does that say to you
well you know carl jung said that the
that which you need the most can be
found in the places you're the most
afraid to look so the darkest place so
you know how he said the way you end the
civil war within your body and your mind
is that and if you want to be a really
effective therapist
you're going to hear people talk and
they're going to tell you [ __ ] that is
going to
curl your toes and freak you out
right and he said the only way to not
pass judgment on people like that is get
in touch with your own shadow you he
called the shadow because we all have a
dark side that's why why some people say
if you really want to be a complete
human being and you want to have no you
want to understand humanity you've got
to imagine yourself being a nazi prison
guard and enjoying it
right and then and then you when you get
in touch with how dark you can be
because we're bipolar apes you'll get in
touch with how how beautiful you can be
on the other side
and and so when we have a judgment on
people over here you got to understand
that that exists in you too 100 so you
we we we occupied the entire [ __ ]
spectrum okay it'll make you a lot less
judgmental and it'll make you a lot more
optimistic in what human beings are
capable angels of our lesser nature
angels of our better nature no doubt i
[ __ ] i like it yeah that's cool how
come you never get into these
conversations no i mean we had we had
that
i feel like it's weird we had a deep one
brian yeah i'm sure why are you not into
that yeah uh i i i'm really i'm good i
promise i'm good i did i i don't need
dmt for life changing no but i mean i'm
wha but what do you think of this
conversation do you agree with what i
said about human beings uh not really
like
uh because i'm trying to recap what you
said you said you got to feel what it's
like to be a nazi prison guard what i'm
saying is that we have a shadow and we
have sure and there's two opposite yeah
two opposites
i think the nazi
um
whatever prison guard is such an extreme
example
that i check out that's the point though
i i get it in two extremes
i think nobody should um
the the viewpoint of that nazi prison
guard is so dark i don't think
everybody's that dark or needs to see
that light i think some people do have
that darkness and can relate to that but
the majority of people are good people
and have no association with that and
can't relate well we're not really
talking about that what i was trying to
say is that
you said looking at human psychology
there's a spectrum and everyone has a
dark side i think i think but i think
everyone's dark side is different i
think for the majority of people's dark
sides not that dark but that's people in
general that's because they've that's
because thank god most of us are able to
live in the middle what i'm what i'm
saying is that there are these two
extremes in life and i think as an
artist just as an example if you want to
write about people like that if you want
to you have to understand that world you
100
should
you you should go into that that
viewpoint i mean yeah one of the great
examples is schizoids or silence of the
lambs the reason that we all kind of
identified with those and those movies
did so well is you see this monster who
touches areas that are [ __ ] the most
perverse horrible schindler's list both
the god the prison guard and that who
who classic example of human beings he
kills jews just for
for sport and then when the woman gets
too close to her he goes don't don't get
too close to me i i don't want to give
you my cold
i don't want to give you my cold you
know i have you in a concentration game
and we all go we all go oh [ __ ] and
that's part of why that movie when part
of why when you study history and you
want to understand how to stop those
kinds of things you go like this you go
this th that evil was done by very
civilized people that evil was done by
people who shave their their their faces
and read girtha and are technologically
advanced and all that stuff you know
slavery was was kept in in place by
people who read all the books and read
all the philosophy
and somehow
or another we missed that
you know somehow or other we were able
to justify it and so it's very very
relevant i think to get in touch with
humanity's dark side and light side and
and that's kind of where that's how you
stop it and you think psychedelics does
that for you
um because i don't know about that i
don't know about that
that's why i'm trying to
when you say i don't tune in because
we're talking about psychedelics you're
talking about crocodiles right so but
then it's like getting in tune with now
that was a different that was a
different point i think you could do
that with psychedelics because it you're
talking about your doctor here's a
better here's a better example of where
i think this is relevant
so one of the reasons they've had a real
success with ptsd people without
psychedelics but just in therapy is when
you tell a young man
so so one of the things that nobody
really talks about is one of the
problems with ptsd is that young men are
in war they do terrible things they went
there to fight bad guys when you're
young they do terrible things
and they come out of it that's one thing
what happens when you do a terrible
thing and in the heat of it
you enjoyed it
now it's a [ __ ] very very difficult
thing to talk about and you don't hear
it a lot because it's really really hard
to talk about but there are people who
are good people who somehow fall into
this strange bloodlust and i'm going to
go a step further which is really [ __ ]
up but there are examples of people who
do terrible things they went to church
they took care of people they're good
people in their heart and they might
have had a heart on when they did it and
i'm going to go further they might have
came when they did it this is the kind
of [ __ ] that psychologists deal with now
hold on you're that's a crisis because
what happens is everything you thought
about yourself goes out the window yeah
and now you're you're the biggest
monster in the world because you got off
on it you actually got off on violence
and then you have a psychologist who
says to you like this he goes well young
man before you kill yourself let me let
me just show you people who've studied
the human psyche like carl young and
freud and these people to a degree
and there's a body of literature that's
so deep to suggest that you're not alone
and that is in every human being if you
really go
into the depths of hell human beings who
are who have been good people did the
most horrible things and then come all
the way back over here and the idea is
you tell a young man everyone has that
horrible side you can't even [ __ ]
look at you can't even admit to it yeah
it's such a secret i i have trouble
talking about living both yeah you know
the reason i know that what i know about
that is because i i studied nazi germany
and i studied the ss and stuff and i
know that there there were a lot of
accounts of this [ __ ]
horrible
thing that happens to human beings
and so when you teach a soldier or you
teach a young man who went to church and
grew up in iowa on a farm with his great
family that everyone has the ability or
a lot of people to there is a shadow to
your side that's all i'm trying to say
and it's helpful man because when you're
young and you're still formulating your
idea of the world it's helpful and it
saves people's lives when they realize
that all there are a lot of people that
went over to that shadow because they
didn't sleep for six days or because
they were so angry or whatever the [ __ ]
happened to them in war war makes a
mockery of your contract with life okay
it's deep [ __ ] that make a lot more so
that's what i'm trying to say what you
what you that's why that's why i'm
interested in it yeah i'm thinking it's
interesting yeah i don't subscribe to it
you know you don't have to yeah but it's
a it's a reality for a lot of people
it's a reality it'd be like this when
people say well i'm an atheist cool i
understand but what but but one of the
things you can always say is that maybe
the best thing you could do as a human
being is to align yourself with your
your concept of the greatest good like
your concept of what your your idea is
in life like so stand-up was always
something you want to do you didn't even
admit it to me until you finally
admitted it and you were like i'm going
to go for this i want to be a comic i
was built for sports awesome but you
know i always say that you were you
sports were kind of put in your body
because you had to do it right but in
your heart you were a comic you wanted
to you wanted to communicate and you and
you always admired people that come up
with something out of nothing and stuff
like that
when you align yourself with that
somehow everything seems to fall into
place i really believe that you kind of
become you become a better better
version of yourself
you can call it whatever you want but i
call that that's got to be some kind of
a higher truth you think i do i think
that that's aligning yourself with with
a truth that you have been either
denying or avoiding and when you when
you accept it you find yourself you find
everything else falls into place it just
does
when you don't and you ignore it what
happens it's like what you were talking
about when you said you wanted to be the
warrior but you were the yes yeah yeah
yeah but i'm i'm the fool and once you
align yourself with that and accept who
you are like whatever your psychic
archetype is whatever you're supposed to
be [ __ ] falls into place when you deny
that that's when we get into this i
think we didn't yeah i agree with when
you deny it's definitely not happening
but i think once you accept it
i think it's a cop i'd say it falls in
place because you make it fall in place
yeah but but you you're inspired so so
there's there's an idea of like the
difference in discipline and inspiration
you can be disciplined to say i'm just
gonna [ __ ] you know i'm not gonna eat
and i'm gonna do all this stuff
i don't think that lasts as long as
inspiration the idea of i want to be
really good at this i want you to
[ __ ] i think you have to have both
100 but the when you the drive to be
really good is going to have that
discipline inherent in it like you're
going to you're going to find yourself
writing because it's what you want to do
and you want to be really good that
that's what i would say to the
discipline will naturally fall in with
the inspiration yeah yeah if you're
honest about it if you really want to do
it what do you why are you doing it this
one doesn't fall because how many comics
do you know who are monster comics but
they don't have to discipline
how many you know um how many athletes
do you know who are monster athletes
don't have the discipline
yeah but but i would say to you in that
case and
if
i don't know if they have the
inspiration
yeah that's what i think
people don't want to just fall into it
yeah because a lot of times people just
do [ __ ]
just just to exist in it hold on you
know the most important thing to realize
about human beings is my biggest
frustration
is
most people
don't do what's good for them i don't
know why
but they just [ __ ] don't
most people don't do what's good for
them they don't yeah they might do a
little bit but that's a good example
where you see people i'm [ __ ] you and
i were talking about somebody today
about this it's like i said this
[ __ ] is the most talented
[ __ ] on the planet nuts and and
and and he is his own worst enemy i see
the [ __ ] and i'm just like and i had to
let it go
because i take it too personally yeah it
hurts my feelings in other ways yeah and
he and i had an experience with it
recently and we were both like i was
like this is one of this this is like a
genius [ __ ] and for whatever
reason just can't
just doesn't want what's best for him i
really believe that and i've seen it for
many many years yeah
and that that's something you got to
come to terms with i don't know what
that is i'm not a psychiatrist but
that's something that there is
you have to come to terms with that you
got to come to terms with why you are
not doing you are not being your best
self i had to deal with that my whole
[ __ ] life yeah but i've kind of part
of like my course correction was
learning how to do that that i think
that comes with a lot of you're a little
bit different bubba you're a little
different you're not as complicated in
your head about that stuff you're just
not but a lot of people are yeah yeah
you know and yeah it's a blessing yeah
it's a blessing i have friends who are
super complicated overthink everything
yeah it's this oh my god i feel bad for
him like dude the demons you have to
[ __ ] grapple with every day right i
don't thank god i don't have those
demons man maybe maybe i gotta do what
it takes what and then i do that yeah
you're not sensitive to you know you
mean you're sensitive your feelings and
stuff but
you know you're you're not a guy who
worries about the discomfort and you and
you don't over think [ __ ] i don't think
about odds i don't think about
discomfort yes i don't think about the
work you just keep going yep just keep
going but a lot of people can't do that
a lot of people for a lot of reasons i
know it's a bummer and it's not like
you're having a trauma and it's not like
you haven't gone through your stuff some
people have a personality yeah it might
be your competitive spirit that kind of
overrides a lot of [ __ ] you're
competitive there's a lot yeah there's a
lot of probably stems from
or
you just don't part of being maybe an
athlete at a high level is that you
gotta get it done or you [ __ ] you
don't lose yeah you lose yeah and then
you get real good at being able to be
like oh it's [ __ ] 30 below and i have
to go out there and hit people and my
bones feel like glass you know thank god
yeah
i don't know
that was a deep conversation you guys
did you write that down everybody yeah
why i got mad that i don't subscribe to
the theory stuff no i didn't get mad
about it sometimes i like the least no i
like to listen too cause sometimes i
don't have uh much to add to that yeah
that's cool
yeah you know it's cool sometimes look
it's either i don't subscribe but if
you're going with it cool i'm still
thinking about into it yeah so sometimes
i'm not into it you know i'm still
trying to i'm still thinking about it
i'm still it's a little bit new to me
because i've i've had to face a lot of
this stuff i've had to go through some
stuff over the past two years where it's
i love learning about it i love it's
just i don't know a lot of people like
that because it's
we all have our
blocks
yeah i think i think for me it's because
you know when i was younger
and i even mentioned this like before i
quit drinking i think i was just so
confused and so like emotionally
disconnected with myself and once i've
found this world this you know
particular thing that we're talking
about
yeah i just felt like oh this is what i
needed to see to be able to do the
things that i want to do you know i i've
used that
as my foundation to be able to get out
all that i'm trying to get out
that's how i look at it
i mean it's too it's also like they say
that with athletes you can't
you cannot overthink [ __ ] or you're dead
like think about being a quarterback and
reading a backfield in a split second
time you even talked about it when you
said you played uh playing tennis
high level football no no when you were
talking about why you never pursued
tennis any further because you said you
would overthink they could well even if
i had the physicality my i think too
much
come on man
i like this combo hey
you'll start when you're four dude yeah
by the way but i'll see even your heart
is making things oh my god a good tennis
player oh my god is it hard oh was that
an episode i missed oh that's why he
wasn't changing no i didn't say hi yeah
that's no he didn't say he didn't say
what i said like you said he'd never be
able to
you wouldn't be able to do it because
you you
it's
or just an athlete in general well i
don't know i have i do not have the
personality type even if i had the body
to play high level tennis you have to
play four or five hours a day i'm
borrowing this quote yeah listen i'm
misquoting you yeah because i don't want
to make it seem like you said
you played
well i think you have a certain kind of
mind to be a high-level athlete because
you can't it was something yes it was
something with athletes but i see this
in my when you know people say say oh
shab has that pro athlete's
work work ethic or mentality you know
rogan's an athlete you know he's not a
professional he's insane workout it's
it's not a uh athletic endeavor as far
as workout no i i you know it's a
competitive my father had worse at
[ __ ] walmart and it has a crazy work
ethic yeah it's just something the way
people are built yeah i know certain
people that are monsters dude and
whether you put them in athletics or ups
post mates sometimes you order postman
you're like holy [ __ ] this person has
three thousand deliveries in a [ __ ]
year
that's the way you make you make the
world a better place by making your tiny
area yeah your tiny little garden and
dominant investigation and dominating it
that's right that's that's yes it's not
a people it's the cop out going that's
an
athletic mentality you know what no i'm
talking about athletes i know that are
competing i'm talking about being
psychologically complicated that's what
i'm talking about yeah but that's with
everything yeah yeah whoever it is yeah
i think art being artistic and being is
is a man some of the some art artists
are
just [ __ ] tortured yeah basket cases
they can do that
mm-hmm
and do well yeah i mean i know and i
mean being in hollywood for as long as i
have the number of like when i see when
i meet super successful people a lot of
them are very very disciplined but then
there are a lot of people like writers
that can write their ass off boy they
can be i mean [ __ ] like
stephen king doesn't remember writing
three books too drunk think about it i
don't remember writing the shining or
[ __ ] he was like i couldn't tell you
what
genius
and you know what he said though he goes
that's because i was a writer with a lot
of talent who had a substance abuse
problem it's not because i was talented
yeah
that's the other thing
so
it's it's we're we're touching on a long
debate that's never
never gonna end the point is when it
comes to spike ball my house
give your address dude it's going to be
good who wants something
i'm going to make a video and you guys
can be like what the [ __ ] dude
he died it does look fun
you got at least played volleyball all
the time so much fun dude
it's to be just so far away would you
ever come down to the beach never never
on what day something had fun though let
me ask on saturday no no no no i'm down
there saturday traffic such a good time
i know we can mean malibu though we
could be malibu i'd do that with you
it's a bit of a beast though it'd be fun
it's so fun kind of you know
you gotta have the right kids what do
you got yeah you got kids now that's the
problem kids
junior ever got into handball or any of
that [ __ ]
handball yeah
nation ball i'm old school so i don't
know all right
no i'm old school i've never heard that
you call it nation ball no this is uh
here sometime
so dodge ball is called nation yeah we
call it nation ball kids can't play
dodgeball in school anymore huh my kids
do my son uh in his private school they
played dodgeball oh really that's
fantastic i mean i read balls dad
there's a kid who can knock you out if
he throws the ball at your head he's
that strong oh well i was like all right
did you get in the face with those
[ __ ] red balls
remember jeff's you we were playing
[ __ ] and joanna's brother who played
baseball was throwing the ball so far
oh my god i threw my arm out he was
throwing that ball like
hey what do you got jen all right
tampa come see me this friday i mean not
this friday april 15 16. uh and then uh
where are you gonna be brent uh i'm in
phoenix arizona april 14-16 that's next
thursday friday saturday phoenix arizona
catch me at jt wings and catch me at
stand up live in phoenix arizona with
the thick boys squad chappelle lacy
david lucas april 14th through the 16th
tickets at thickboy.com
dude with more folks hitting the road
more actions are happening i see it
non-stop and you know who's you know
who's benefiting from this insurance
because their rates are jacked up
luckily for us our friends at the zebra
they're here to help man the zebra
compares car and home coats for every
major insurance company side by side
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision fastest way to
find the right coverage at the right
price all year from a provider you can
trust the zebra saves people an average
of 922 dollars a year on car and home
insurance takes just five freaking
minutes save time and money in minutes
show your support for this show by going
to this special url the zebra.com
fighter and get your free quote today
that's the zebra.com fighter
so this is a little older but i thought
this was hilarious there is a brazilian
singer who was hospitalized after she
was holding in her farts while she was
spending time with her boyfriend i guess
they were at a stage in their
relationship where she didn't feel
comfortable farting around him and she
would
spend it spend an extended amount of
time with him where she just held it in
and it built up so much gas in her body
it caused her physical pain she then
went down a google spiral where people
said you know what this pain should
diminish it's fine
just like fart when you can and it got
so bad she went to the hospital and when
they got there she held her farts for
like days yeah days and it kept
happening because every time she would
hang out with her boyfriend for a few
days she would hold in her farts she
just refused to at least walk into the
other room that's what i was thinking
like maybe
no put a silencer use the pillow i use
the pillow and i use it as a bomb the
silence
i don't know how you're gonna give
someone a pink eye like that yeah
i'd rather that than the er
and she actually admitted it on
instagram because she was just making a
silly story like hey guys you know
what's more embarrassing than farting in
front of your boyfriend it's waking him
up in the middle of the night to take
you to the hospital only to be told that
you've been holding in your farts i
wonder what he said after like goddamn
girl no justin accumulation
yeah a lot of those uh spanish singers
crazy oh she's a singer yeah so if you
hold your fart you can go up jesus
christ 15.7 million followers
she's super bad
stunning
yeah she's very pretty so did they have
to cut her open
no she was giving some medication to
kind of
yeah dude
yeah i mean i don't know dude this is a
seri this is a rare case no probably
that's a fair question
well she's very very very pretty now how
much of that is natural
uh
not a lot a lot but also who cares
though you know the lips don't care
kids don't care
all right
all right yeah she's she's doing well
god it must have been bad
farts in so bad right but don't you do
that no you i'll let let it go silencer
i'll go uh i think i left some in the
kitchen and my girl stay upstairs and i
just go down and it's [ __ ] bombs over
bags yeah do you still do like replaying
the trumpets down there i'm like nope so
after all this time you still don't fart
never keep yourself interesting never
never never never good discipline once
you have sex somebody that's farting all
the time some people are i've never
heard my girl fart don't worry what nine
years never heard her fart ever
not even asleep she's about she's not
feel the emergency room
it's good for her
for you discipline man discipline
oh god my kids are farting excuse me
because she makes them take some like
don't say excuse me just fart dude fart
hard let it out yeah and then they get
another because i'll walk in their
bedroom in the morning i thought that's
a fart and i'll fart in his bed and
they'll be like dad say excuse me like
i'm not gonna say that because i'm not a
nerd okay
excuse me what are you what are you
[ __ ] richie rich what is this dude
excuse me excuse me
dad farts hard my friend my friend's uh
my sister's friend she's a bigger girl
and she was laughing
and she bent over
and she just went
i felt so bad and i just went like that
and she goes she goes excuse me and i go
what yeah i'd pretend like
because you wouldn't i got
and my sister goes i started laughing i
was like i didn't hear dude it's so
embarrassing when you rip a fart we
don't mean to the last time i remember
doing that as i was staying with klopp i
when i was i was an ultimate fighter his
apartment downtown and he was with his
girlfriend who's now his wife she was
staying there we're all watching the
show together like american idol or some
[ __ ]
and i just i was whole i was like a fart
bad and then i just went to mook because
she goes okay she goes hey can you scoot
over
i go like this
and he goes
i just stopped and went
i like the tap of the thought
i just stopped and went
and she was like wow i'm so sorry i just
i'm so sorry clap close how's your call
go unbelievable
sometimes it happens man yeah
it does
what are you gonna do
farts are never not funny
a man in the bronx was in the er when
the the doctor who had
come to check his dick
realized like hey your dick is turning
black it's actually dying what did you
do
and the guy admitted to administering
coke into his dick
several times into the hole
uh he was trying to inject it i believe
like in the shaft not necessarily in the
pee hole crack
uh but he had a bunch of other things in
his system he had meth injected
he said that he's done it a few times
before and it was perfectly fine but the
last time he did complications but he
shot cannabis and methadone in his dick
too
uh i believe
i don't see
by the way your room tests all came back
positive for cocaine
i don't know if he actually administered
those through his dick as well but
that's just what they found in his his
system yeah hey obviously this guy's
super smart but dude after
after all the do you know me places you
can inject your body the vein of your
dick daddy but if he does this a lot it
could be most of his veins or veins as
other places yeah go to your goals
they'll go hands-on do intervention
style go to yeah some people do between
like toes yeah yeah the web of the foot
go back
he probably did all that dude
so many drugs like [ __ ] i'm just putting
this big juicy dick thing yeah that is
look at this even if you have a small
dick that juice juicy vein is thick yeah
you can't miss it what'd you see brian
what and penis rots after cobra bit man
oh he wasn't like that
oh no believe it though oh no what do
you think is that true click on it chin
alrighty
to wrap up that story though that guy
was told that his dick is technically
like just a dead appendage and he would
have to have it chopped off he refused
took some medication from the doctor to
try to help revive it in any way and we
have not heard from him sis since
we don't know dutchman has suffered
rotting penis after cobra bit his
genitals while sitting on the toilet
south africa all set
uh oh contains extremely graphic videos
or photos let's definitely click on that
hold on you're trying to see three hours
before you'd be flown to the nearest
hospital approximately 220 miles away
his penis scrotum was were noted to be
swollen you think deep purple in color
painful on a house shut up you don't
want to get bit by a cobra especially
not in the dick
he except he wanted extensive
reconstruction surgery required
hemodialysis treated injuries sustained
to his kidneys
he's made a full recovery and a plastic
surgeon performed a penal shaft
debridement
uh
extensive reconstructive surgery
man's made a full recovery dude stuff
that guy's injecting cocaine this guy
got bit by a [ __ ] coat hey dude
they have pictures of it i don't know
i'd like to see him
dude think about a cobra
[ __ ] latching onto your dick no
that's not good at all cobras are stupid
poisonous yeah super um but also i don't
know if this is true
might be
oh yeah it showed
that's after the that's probably after
the cobra is good aim yeah it's after
the uh
it's after the one yeah
operation after the operation that would
hurt
yeah that's a lot you showed another one
man in india kills wife by cobra yeah i
believe it just
that's what they do to them huh what's
that one
india they would always blame it on a
cobra bite so you kill your wife in a
fight and a fit of rage and then they'd
be like uh cobra better nothing to see
here and i already buried her that's
what they would do no
that's what's that one crazy snake oh
they got gaboon
viper yeah no and no one like that two
inch fangs
no you're not [ __ ] i don't want
anything bite my dick yeah uh your boy
logan paul was uh performing at
wrestlemania killed it yeah i'll be able
to be on a show end of april
you see him just do the splits yeah
he's been able to do that amazing
his vine videos he had like a
compilation of him just dropping in to
the splits
dude he's [ __ ] great hey shout out to
him for that great that's right
was on there too
he is
dude this is dope he puts in the work
man does he ever look at this
he's taking over the [ __ ] world right
look at him he he's a natural
yeah he's as good as anybody we've seen
him watch some job
james brown
god damn that's as good as anybody pat
mcafee was on there too
wow
that's dope boys are blowing
so louis ck actually won a grammy last
night for the best comedy album he was
not there in attendance so
levar burton was the one to go up and
again from reading rainbow yep
threw some shade on louis ck
uh i did not get to see the full uh
speech he's just excited forced
awkwardly accept i love that you want a
grammy how great is that yeah that's a
great spell i wish my boy nate barghazzi
won but he was up for it there's dave
chappelle him
good for louie isn't that cool that's a
big deal
that is [ __ ] awesome great special
yeah one of the best can you even say
that he's cancelled by hollywood anymore
if they're the ones who nominated him no
that's not it's not right well the the
grammys had to come out and be like hey
we don't give a [ __ ] what's going on
outside it's just the body of work all
we do is nominate the body of work
whatever happens outside we have no
control of we just dominate the body of
work
yep
pretty cool undeniable i love it
speaking of which i'll be in tampa
15th and 16th
that's this week get your tickets i
don't know two next two weeks two weeks
and my special
may 19th it's official may 19th shooting
it there yeah yeah it's not gonna come
out for a while but yeah yeah shooting
it get your tickets cool uh this is a
little bit late but we want to make sure
to show up chappelle had his concert
what two weeks ago a week and a half ago
so just a little clip of them come on
man
i like the guy holding his girl there
is that a hot topic there are just two
people watching
this is not a hot topic
it's at a skate shop record store called
program
in uh fullerton
you write the lyrics you and the i wrote
i wrote the whole song you and the
bassist are some thick boys huh yeah
yeah
[Applause]
yeah it was great yeah when's the next
one
um
we don't have we don't have one books
right now we're gonna set some up what
what'd you say talk all your [ __ ] no i
didn't no no go ahead i'm asking him no
no i can't make fun of my fourth time
literally asking him making his guitar
collection i haven't said it you're
making fun of his [ __ ] yeah
how do you make fun of you get up there
brian
that's a good song
that's a good song we need to do it
again hey hold on
chappelle all i was asking was brennan
that's the one that's one didn't support
him brandon was showing he was brandon
was so supportive brandon was shooting
with the next one brandon was showing
like enthusiasm because when's the next
one and in my mind it sounded like he
was saying
when's the next one
and the subtext was
so i can come and watch you and the
reason i
looked at brennan and said why
is because if you had 30 grand
waiting for him
there
he ain't coming no
now i'm not trying to be a dick but he
can't come
no if it was
right after finding the kids
so when he goes
when's the next one just me like once he
like wants to bang in together man nope
don't mean i'll be there
i can just see on his face and i just go
y'all think i'm a weirdo no we don't
yeah you do no we know yeah you do no oh
yeah you do i love you oh yeah you do i
love you oh yeah you do you thought it
was dope
ryan look at him look it up right
your handball story and then poor
chabelle here by the way when you
describe your trips it's like nothing
happens
no yours he didn't [ __ ] with me
i'm like [ __ ] up and i'm like i gotta
go to the airport we have to hurry and
he goes i just gotta stop by the dmv for
a second i go no no no no
no just to register my car go then that
bet he goes no okay okay and we're
driving anything i think it goes because
just to register my car go we don't have
time man
freaked me out
i gotta pee so bad jim before we do this
what else you got jen
all right this is the next one that we
talked about is that will happen but i
guess it's happening pretty soon bts all
of them
will have to join
military service for one and a half
years yeah so so one point five years
ago you look like the one on the far
left is going to struggle a little bit
i mean
like a guy with mascara
super feminine because they all have to
do it at a certain age right yeah
yeah super creamy no matter how famous
you are it doesn't matter everyone does
military green zombie lost to jose aldo
and then went away for three years
two years
how long how long did they have to do
three years it's usually a minimum two
year service
but depending on what you do like if you
my dad did the marine thing so he had he
was had the option of serving one and a
half because it's tougher yeah he ended
up serving three years because of a
threat from north korea
so it just depends that's a tough yeah
you think they would have some like kind
of exceptions like with bts like
no matter how famous you are no matter
how familiar
the rock would have to go if he was
there it's kind of badass yeah a bunch
of bts fans try to make a protest
the government's like excuse me they're
like because i guess there are certain
exceptions for people not to go right if
you're like uh
what's the term the chin correct me if
i'm wrong in korean culture in korean
culture if they did take the exception
it would be frowned upon
yeah yeah
you you would be it would [ __ ] your your
sales up
not just that there's a the most famous
guy at the time was yu seung jun who's a
k-pop one of the first k-pop artists
yeah he found a way to go to the u.s and
get citizenship to not serve he's no
longer allowed in korea wow he was the
biggest at the time too no no no
korean's [ __ ] they don't [ __ ] let
them back in that's the market but does
the i'm saying do the koreans still
support him even though he can't go back
in i mean
but just not the government
there was a tabloid guy they they posted
a nude picture i remember
of this k-pop star this girl because the
boyfriend sold it to some guy and he and
you had him on the video trying to sell
sell it to other people and you hear the
editors going [ __ ] you like in korean
like [ __ ] you you scumbag one newspaper
that was well known
bought it right
no one bought the paper
they shut that [ __ ] down that's great
everybody in the [ __ ] country went oh
that's what you do [ __ ] yeah
because america is not like
you know if the
safety of south korea nothing against
bts comes down to them defend the
country could get dicey you know
because they're in like gucci [ __ ]
dresses i'm sure
i mean they're going to learn a lot
being in them they will learn a lot
they're definitely not going to have the
same kind of treatment they're going to
have they're going to have to go through
some tough times but there's no way they
get the same treatment as a regular they
know it was coming naturally but they
might want it you know i don't know
maybe
nope i don't think so
well but i mean just the stuff that they
when you're touring the world
their training and stuff is already
rigorous even though it's just a pop-up
yeah they're going hours that they put
into yeah stuff yeah if you're a big
touring artist and they're like hey you
gotta take a break
yeah like why did i dance dude
you asked in this machine
yeah yeah and dan's assassin
walk over here [ __ ]
going pop locked and rock on this
grenade right
that guy's a looker though that guy who
went to america to get american
citizenship he should have known him oh
yeah he was he was on top of the world
he looks like a tough dude
he does like stunt stuff in china i
think damn that's all yeah so he was
huge and he can't
that's him he didn't know that was gonna
be suicide right that was the look back
then
the one long yep i had that too he's
almost like a misfits double lock guy
they're looking in there on the side
yeah he's a beast looking guy man that's
a [ __ ] scenario you have to know
doing that
he was begging crying to come back and
they just said nope oh no do that if you
yeah yeah you can't do that i'm the
rules
also it's just two yeah two years
i know imagine being the biggest star
but they just don't let you in because
of that imagine like justin bieber
having to [ __ ] go to war right now
dude that's what they're doing
did you see his outfit last training
you never go back to your country though
yeah that's the sad thing yeah yeah dude
just do the two years yeah that's what
i'm saying two years
let me get this what's this
this meteorologist was actually looking
at us
like a big tornado that's coming to a
certain area he realized it was
right where he lives oh so he called his
kids to make sure they went to the
basement hide for like a few minutes
i'll show you here very very closely uh
as a matter of fact i'm i'm tracking
this uh so closely now uh this is gonna
go
this is gonna go right over
uh right over my house so very close to
my house
which again is in the chevy chase area
bethesda area uh this is along wisconsin
avenue as well so heads up if you live
along massachusetts or wisconsin avenue
can't you in there buddy
yeah all right hey man i want you to uh
get down in the in the basement we got a
tornado warning all right so i want to
make sure you and you and callie get
downstairs as soon as you can okay
yeah get down there right now yeah yeah
we have wi-fi down there dad just kind
of wait for like 10-15 minutes okay
do it now all right thanks buddy
all right so that was uh you know got to
warn my kids because i know swedes are
doing right now they're probably online
gaming and they're not seeing this so
[Laughter]
i i went to college there and i never
saw a tornado come through dc that's
really what i know it's rare in those
parts yeah and there are a lot of
buildings in bethesda chevy chase a lot
of buildings so it's very that's very
suspect to me and strange oh well i mean
that's a really
residential like i love he's like as i
look closer holy [ __ ] that's my house
right over my head because i live right
in the chevy chase area
never heard of a tornado going through
that area dude and we used to have
tornadoes in colorado all the time the
tornado warnings and we'd go to the
basement i used to love it were they big
tornadoes like the ones
that's got hail correct
the animals that die like rabbits will
just get plugged [ __ ]
all right this is a little disturbing
but the guy's okay now this officer is
okay
well i saw she saw this
and it's almost like a horror movie
because you don't think she's gonna do
anything she looks like a crazy oh she's
no but he's like all right let's go this
way and she's trying to help her
apparently she crashed and he's trying
to help her you wanna be a cop huh
everybody wants to fund the police watch
this
he runs this crazy girl just a normal
time for him hello
what's going on
this is a cop in a nutshell you have no
idea what you're getting it's a girl you
wouldn't really expect something like
this to happen well it's the segment
what's going on
this is a knife behind her back a huge
don't walk away
no no walking come over here
okay
usually the knife behind her back
walk upstairs all right let's get out
this water area
you're scared
all right let's walk up here let's get
off this water okay
see she has the knife on her side we
walk
right here
what's this
but he's fine now they said if there's
any other like a little bit down he
probably wouldn't would have made it and
then nuts yeah and that was it and then
mm-hmm
attempted for charge
or something i don't know she's an
[ __ ] that's not a drug she's an
[ __ ] what else is going on with this
[ __ ] cuckoo bird
yeah not much surgery since the knife
nicked his cardboard artery
but he's already gone home whoa dude
he's gonna make a little recovery
he's out of the hospital he's a cop huh
oh man they they deal with that every
day people don't realize what they say
random calls some crazy [ __ ] beach big
titties you know crazy [ __ ]
wait can i just can i just he's just
like what's up knife in the net we know
much about her history that [ __ ]
whacking oh
i don't think we need to look too much
into it i think she uh she's just
clueless doodle i mean she i think she
has to be on drugs
oh here we go
involved
traffic traffic crash
okay
she's how she's super [ __ ]
imagine doing that man you're so screwed
now attempt premeditated attempted
murder you're gone for a hot second
premeditated that's trippy um
butterfly tonight
butterfly knife jesus
and what would you say you're going to
say in the neck and run away
and then you kill a cop what do you
think this ends well are you dumb dumb
right and you're on camera you're
[ __ ]
the moment
searching for the woman
[Music]
that's her she's pretty
she oh be pretty i mean you did too much
damn too dude maybe but she's just you
thought she was pretty
she's got nice eyes i can see her if she
was not a killer and a complete fuck-up
uh let's do it prepared on my shoulders
she alleges she had no car insurance
scared of going to jail
oh my god for that reason she stabbed
him the freaking neck ah
she did she went out of fear with the
knife she brought
she didn't tend to kill him so she's
crazy yeah i mean drugs i'm sure well
thankfully the officer is going to be
perfectly fine after this insane dude
[Music]
um
i know we're tired of the will smith
thing but i just saw this on hood clips
[Applause]
people find all this stuff later on
uh i don't want to know what they found
on um
chris rock's face after
oh no
joke no
fresh prince
hell yeah
fresh prince no i love it
ship those
fresh prince
all right
this is a sad one very sad and this is
just trippy too it's so this kid fell
from a 430 foot
ride
at icon theme park in orlando have you
seen the actual video of him falling no
i hope
star had it all hell no don't watch that
well so so the thing is about these
rides
i told us all the time some 18 year old
kid doesn't want to be there getting
paid minimum wage he's you know he's
just like whatever dude
then this kid he's he's 14 years old
live 340 pounds well that's insane it's
not strapped
to the football player he's not strapped
incorrectly he's telling his friends
like hey if i don't want to do this if i
die tell my parents this this and this
dude it goes up he's freaking out and
then comes you know i go screeching down
and like
like kind of breaks
i i'm not laughing as it screech down
you see him go what yep
it's horrible i just it just he just
broke out
yeah i mean just really yeah because it
wasn't because it wasn't strapped yeah
one of the workers comes up to this like
so this guy's like you know 20 some made
terrible decisions like he's like the
green light was on it was fine
he's 340 pounds like what's he doing on
there oh there's a light that tells him
like everyone's
it was all the lights were green it
seemed strange still like i think how
the parents are suing that so the thing
stopped and how far did he fall
400 or whatever i thought that's how
tylenol
you know you can start thinking about
when it comes to down at how many 100
miles an hour or something whatever and
when it screeches when it comes slowing
down you know you probably fall 60 feet
felt broke is that what happened we
don't know because he was 53 pounds over
the weight limit already so probably
40 at that age
i know these football players gigantic
uh there was an article about a woman
coming out saying she was like his
cousin trying to receive donations she
made like a fake memorial for him
are you serious
terrible terrible person
she's like crying in front of cameras oh
my gosh my cousins were trying to like
collect money for him i'm sure people
donated a terrible person yeah but what
happened this is how stupid people are
what happens is gofundme the way it
works they realize that and they take
all the money yeah the people that
donate get their money back yeah good i
started asking for donations at their
like jesus christ like in person too
because there are people coming up
trying to like send their condolences i
know the parents are suing the the theme
park
like whatever 15 million dollars
my friend was in an accident
and got really hurt and a lawyer as he's
being loaded onto the [ __ ] ambulance
laura goes call me i can make you some
money
yeah that's what they do thanks
i don't know man yeah
he he
hits hard and then the guy right it's
like he's like we need 9-1-1 and the
parents are watching oh no it's tough
dude what a disaster that's [ __ ]
world star [ __ ] wrong
that's tough well i saw rogan post this
the house passed a bill to federally
decriminalize marijuana
no this is not real and it's also uh so
i think it's retroactive too so the
people that didn't do any non-violent
crimes they won't be charged with the
you know how they were going to jail
yeah that's great that's really good so
in other words expunges
so expunges the records of convicted
non-violent cannabis offenses which i
imagine would be so many people are
going to get let go it's great
yeah what can you go over to the um just
for another one
for research now that looks like you
don't want to click on that
i'm just curious
it's on cnn how is this popping up i
mean because i think it's
paid content yeah remember well
did you do anything for april fools we
on thick boy instagram we posted that i
mean it looked like a real article i'm
announced and i've come back to oh yeah
yeah yeah i saw it i obviously people
know it was april fools and one guy
really got on there was like you have a
lot going on for you man you don't need
to do this
i was like holy [ __ ] this guy didn't
realize it's april fools
there it is meanwhile a real reporter
april fools 2022. that's really funny
there you go baby it's almost thought
that was actual real in it says by a
real reporter i know and it says april
fool's literally a guy down there was
like you don't need to do this man you
have a lot going on seems like a bad
idea i was like oh who cares about you
man brandon versus dalia finally going
down let's go chris
let's go chris
all right um speaking of fighting
someone just sent this in i don't
remember his name but someone sent this
in
look at this thing
holy [ __ ] oh that ref tried though you
know
knocked out there there there
oh yeah
that's like that that's bad axe kick
which always look it doesn't look like
it's not doing anything but that ref
tried getting in there but then yeah it
was quick on it yeah somebody hashtag
super necessary
yes
[ __ ] oh and this last one then
did you guys know this comedian jarrod
michael i love drawing carmichael
my
so he came out as gay on a special he's
amazing did you know he was a gay man we
didn't know i didn't know i just loved
him i think he was kind of like under
yeah but people kind of knew people
would like no like they're not that
surprised people that knew yeah some
people yeah i don't know him at all yeah
she's he's funny he's just he's a
beautiful guy man in every way just that
guy's an artist oh he's in big in
hollywood too we knew we knew that i
mean he does a lot i mean he's like a
show runner for quite a few years he had
his own show yeah he had the car with
the carmichaels yeah he came from
nothing too he's like it's you know he's
real good friends with jamar
oh man that's so cool man she comes out
in the special yeah yeah love it
if it's funny i love it he was so gutsy
back then man he did he would do [ __ ] we
were at the comedy store in la jolla and
he was what
23. didn't you and dove buy him a car
was his first cars we did that's the
rumor yeah that would be the rumor
that's the rumor nice that's the rumor
because i thought you said it was like
this kid was like
the train or the bus he's just too
special i was like you can't you never
know what buying somebody a car who's
worth it you know it's like hit them up
now i'm like hey dude
you saw that hbo special hey uh remember
that car that i got you years back give
me a little stomach daddy's been charged
in interest for 15 years now
i love he's one of the good guys where i
just hear good things and i'm like yes
that's cool man he kind of he kind of
keeps to himself too
he's always been that way yeah
recluse thoughtful
dude and never wanted to be involved
all right kids uh wednesday is shopping
friends hollywood improv 8 p.m we got
some monsters might have a very special
guest pop on up crystalia chappelle
david lucas the monsters are out one
show only at 8 pm
the next week i'm sorry saturday is the
thick mud or tough mudder it's 10 30 a.m
start time we have the 15k and 5k go to
tough mudder you'll see the thick boy
tough mudder uh start time there use
promo code thank you for you to be okay
i'm sorry this time i'm gonna be fine i
have two hamstrings what's the promo
code uh thick boy 10 off uh which
actually helps on the it's like 120
bucks to sign up but there's a 15k and
5k come around with the thick boys thick
motors at 10 30 a.m in uh with san
bernardino yeah california yeah
it's right there at that raceway out
there that's at 10 30 a.m this freaking
saturday we have 470 people signed up
god damn so we got bigger than the
livestream ready for uh
for the fight companion oh yeah i'll
make the fight companion at 7 p.m live
for ufc 273 we have matt matrion brian
cal and josh thompson myself i love it
that goes 7 p.m live for ufc 273.
we gotta come on comes out gilbert burns
right yup can't wait man
and then next week is phoenix you're up
i'll be full of jt wings and a positive
attitude april 14th 16th thursday friday
saturday phoenix arizona stand up live
then austin texas is april 22nd through
the 23rd two shows friday two shows
saturday
at the moon tower economy festival at
cap cities uh austin texas and then
april 28th on thick boy my special
debuts get you some man
self
motivated self done self paid for you'll
see uh everything that we're doing man
that drops april 28th on thick boy
youtube only but phoenix you're up next
thursday friday saturday
tampa tampa improv i got friday saturday
april 16 15 and 16. get your tickets
tampa improv port charlotte florida
vasani comedy theater april 21 22-23
that's thursday friday saturday then las
vegas nevada wise guys comedy club
april 28th to the 30th and guess who's
coming to new jersey at the stress
factory ladies oh daddy said the jersey
stress factory jersey i said [ __ ] it may
5 6 7. it's really only a month out but
i said i'm doing this uh i love the
stress factory only done it once before
love jersey love those crowds
stress factory i'll see you there new
jersey new braun new brunswick brunswick
yeah
there we go and then uh this weekend
april 8th and april 9th friday saturday
i'll be at wise guys comedy club in salt
lake city then uh later later down the
road may 6th and may 7th i'll be in san
diego at mike drop comedy club new
comedy club out there in san diego and
then i'll be doing a one night or may
12th in the hometown phoenix at stand up
live
all righty
boom love you guys love ya